good evening mr miller
five years ago the outgoing labour
treasury minister left a message there's
no money left
how can we trust the labour party with
the uk economy we just saw it by the way
because
let me uh directly address you elizabeth
there was a global financial crisis
there was a high deficit that deficit
hasn't been cleared it will be the
mission of my government to cut the
deficit every year and balance the books
and let me tell you how i'm going to do
it first of all we'll have fair taxes so
we'll reverse david cameron's tax cut
for the richest in our society
millionaires i can't justify a 43 000
pound tax cut for every millionaire in
britain secondly we'll protect key areas
like health and education but outside
those key areas there will be falls in
spending because we've got to get the
deficit down but the final thing
concerns your living standards we've
seen living standards fall over this
parliament as a result lower living
standards means lower tax revenues for
government and that's why the deficit
hasn't been cleared so it's a three-part
plan to make sure we balance the books
but